Now that we have a database that's not
empty, let's start reading from it.
In the last video, you saw me call
session.query(Restaurant).all.
If I create a variable called
firstResult and set it equal to
session.query(Restaurant) and
use .first this time,
I now have a variable that corresponds
to a single row in my database.
These single row references allow me to
extract column entries as method names.
So if I were to write firstResult.name,
I'm given the name of my restaurant
object as it is stored in the database.
Currently, I only have one restaurant
and one menu item stored in my database.
Well that's kind of boring, but with
the help from some fellow Udations I've
created a Python script that will
populate my database with several
different restaurants and menu items
popular amongst the Udasity team.
Download the lotsofmenus.py script
into your working directory and
execute it from the command line as so.
Now when we perform executions like
session.query(Restaurant).all,
we get back a whole list of results.
So what happens when I have a query
that returns a collection of results and
we want to display column
information for each item?
For this, we can use a python for loop
to return the data that we want to see.
Here, let's do an example.
I will make a variable called items and
set it equal to a query that
retrieves all of my menu items.
Now, I can say for
item in items, print item.name.
Now I get back a printed line of
each item name in our database.
SQL Alchemy has an extensive
collection of queries we can perform on
our database.
Take some time to explore
the query documentation here and
play around with the database for
a while.
When you're ready,
move on to some of the challenge
problems in the next section.